en el último vídeo usamos el teorema de
la divergencia para demostrar que el
flujo el flujo del campo vectorial a
través de esta superficie la que la que
la frontera de esta región r era igual a
la suma de la divergencia de fs es lo
que nos dice el teorema de la libertad
el teorema de la divergencia que es la
suma de esta divergencia de efe a lo
largo de toda la región completita r y
eso nos dio como resultado igual a 0 y
la idea de este vídeo es pensar un poco
en por qué la respuesta es 0 esto nos
está diciendo que no hay flujo que si
sumamos toda la divergencia en este
volumen vamos a obtener 0 pero por qué
por qué ocurre esto y bueno la razón o
una forma de pensarlo es que la
divergencia nos dio 2 x 2 x es decir la
divergencia aumenta a medida que
aumentamos en x entonces si por ejemplo
nos vamos moviendo en esta dirección
digamos hacia acá
si nos vamos moviendo de esta forma
entonces x va aumentando su valor de
forma positiva entonces la divergencia
va a ser positiva ahora más aún este
tenemos aquí que si nos vamos en la
dirección contraria
vamos a tener una divergencia negativa
entonces a medida que nos vamos alejando
de este eje y vamos haciendo de este
lado que sea más positivo y del otro
lado que sea más negativo de hecho como
la divergencia sólo depende de x es lo
mismo si nos alejamos a cualquiera
a cualquier altura verdad si nos vamos
alejando a esta altura digamos también
va aumentando y en la misma digamos en
la misma proporción
de hecho esta región r es simétrica
respecto al plano y ez es decir a este
plano formado por estos dos ejes
entonces si nos tomáramos digamos sólo
sólo esta mitad digamos la mitad del
plan hoy ese está hacia los valores de x
positivo
esto es estaremos pensando en esta que
está esto que estoy marcando esto que
voy a marcar va a ser digamos el muro
trasero
el muro trasero de de la sección que nos
interesa es decir vamos a cortar la
superficie a la mitad sí y está esto que
estoy marcando en morado es lo que va a
ser el muro trasero de la de la parte de
esta superficie que nos interesa es de
hecho déjenme déjenme ir quitando por
ejemplo vamos a ir borrando esto
esto ya no va a ser parte voy a hacerlo
un poquito más grande porque si no me
voy a tardar mucho vamos a quitar toda
esta parte
esto ya no nos va a interesar estudiarlo
y bueno de hecho también tendría que
quitar esta otra parte
complicado entonces si sólo nos quedamos
con esta mitad de la superficie aquí
entonces la equis ya no se mueve entre
menos uno y uno en realidad se está
moviendo entre 0 y 1 si quitamos solo la
parte negativa que es lo que vamos a
obtener bueno esencialmente va podríamos
hacer todo todo igual todo igual pero
cuando lleguemos a esta integral ya no
va a ir de menos uno a uno va a ir de
cero a uno y entonces esto ya no va a
ser de menos 11 sino va a ir de 0 a 1 y
esta parte se va a ser cero entonces qué
es lo que vamos a obtener vamos a
obtener tres medios menos un medio que
es dos medios que es uno y a ese uno hay
que quitarle un sexto entonces vamos a
obtener cinco sextos cinco sextos es el
valor del flujo de este lado pero como
la superficie es simétrica entonces del
lado del de los valores de x negativos
vamos a obtener exactamente 5 sextos que
fue lo que obtuvimos acá abajo pero con
signo negativo éste
una interpretación que podemos dar es
decir si consideramos la región entera
como en el vídeo pasado tenemos que de
un lado es positivo y del otro lado es
negativo de la misma magnitud pero en el
de signos opuestos